[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mardi avant
novembre dix ans de transmission depuis
2008 le salon histoire de lire partage
l'histoire plus de cent soixante auteurs
ils sont attendus
joris lacoste et emmanuel lafont se
mettent à hauteur des enfants bla bla
bla l'encyclopédie de la parole
mix des extraits sonores prix dans le
présent des petits et des grands
elle a envoûté le théâtre simone
signoret de conflans sainte honorine
console sarah lenka jouer pour
blues-sur-seine la semaine dernière est
la nouvelle exposition du théâtre espace
coluche est une rencontre celle d'une
artiste peintre et d'un plasticien serge
guarnieri et christine besson se
partagent l'espace et font se répondent
de leurs oeuvres
la nature qui évolue au fil des saisons
des époques
christine vaisseau sans l'inspiré la
transcrit sur ses toiles en venant tout
à l'heure sur l'autoroute
j'étais à l'arrêt et j'ai vu les
ak c'est en ce moment qu'il change de
couleur et y avait un camaïeu de vert
bleu et ça tout de suite ça ça attire
mon attention la nature m'apporte
beaucoup
l'artiste parisienne travaille par sévit
elle peint jusqu'à 40 toiles par an
christine bessonart il est technique en
travaillant beaucoup avec du papier une
texture particulière pour emmener le
public dans un univers ma peinture j'ai
pas trop envie que ce soit conceptuel
j'ai envie que les gens rentrent dans ma
peinture
ma peinture c'est mes émotions mais j'ai
envie que les gens écrivent une histoire
cette série gelé
et appeler passe-muraille que les gens
juste justement trouve une petite faille
dans mes tableaux une nature un vivant
qui inspire aussi serge guarnieri une
inspiration de l'infiniment petit et de
l'infiniment grand
ça peut être
minéral végétal animal mais l'impulsion
c'est-à-dire un embryon un bourgeon le
big bang
le micro causse tout ce qui est
bactériologique
le tout début que l'impulsion de la vie
c'est également
c'est pour ça que je me suis aussi
beaucoup de l'eau ce que l'eau est venu
enfin la vie est venue de l'odon tout ce
qui est fonds marins
les habits sont en général serge garnier
imagine ainsi navy primaire l'artiste
sculpte des matières exigeantes comme le
fer à béton
ces oeuvres recréer le mouvement des
êtres vivants je me suis toujours
intéressé à la nature depuis tout petit
en fin de compte rien qu'un petit pierre
m'inspirait enfin j'observais énormément
et c'est la nature qui va et qui m'a
conduit à ça en fin de compte à à
chercher à imaginer à comprendre leurs
oeuvres se répondent et s'interpellent
christine besson et serge guarnieri
expose jusqu'au 14 janvier
un autre rendez-vous exposition celui-ci
se passe à magny les hameaux les
aquarellistes de l'arc donne rendez vous
à la maison des bonnes heures jusqu'au
dimanche de décembre vous pourrez
découvrir leurs plus belles oeuvres
le livre d'histoire est à la portée de
tous les publics et ce week-end c'est la
onzième édition du salon histoire de
lire des animations des débats des
échanges ont fait le point avec notre
invité xavier malin le commissaire du
salon
bonjour bonsoir cette année encore plus
d'une centaine d'auteurs conviés je
confirme maintenant je crois qu'on bat
un record 177 auteurs on va recevoir que
quinze mille livres pour accueillir
vingt mille visiteurs pendant tout le
week-end et parmi ces auteurs des grands
noms du beau monde
alors on a toujours si vous voulez
l'actualité les livres importants des
grands historiens emmanuel de waresquiel
jean christian petitfils mais à côté de
ça effectivement on a eu tous ceux qui
aiment et qui écrivent l'histoire donc
aujourd'hui s'appelle lorànt deutsch qui
nous raconte l'histoire romanesque de la
langue française
michael lonsdale voilà ça peut des
romanciers jean marie rouart clara
dupont aignan qui est l'histoire au sens
large c'est les livres historiques comme
les livres de fiction
absolument je parlais de romans
historiques que là on sort on sort du
travail d'essayiste mai mais voilà quand
clara dupont-monod nous nous parle
d'aliénor d'aquitaine
on apprend aussi plein de plein de plein
de choses sur cette période et sa
relation avec son fils richard coeur de
lion enfin
voilà à travers le roman à travers la bd
bien sûr histoire se décline sous toutes
ses formes à ce ne sont pas que des
auteurs on va dire qu'il tape des textes
il ya la baie de la bande dessinée tout
à fait est là depuis quelques années
nombre d'historiens se sont lancés eux
aussi dans l'écriture de a scénarisé
l'histoire en bande dessinée
donc on a je crois une trentaine une
trentaine d'auteurs de bandes dessinées
qui seront là l'idée d'un tel salon ces
de partager l'histoire avec tout le
monde faire comprendre que tout le monde
peut la lire cette histoire c'est
vraiment la transmission d'une d'une
passion voilà pour que l'on comprenne
pourquoi on célèbre on commémore le
centenaire de la fin de la guerre de 14
pourquoi la france est devenue le centre
du monde avec 70 chefs d'état il ya
quelques jours voilà avoir un regard sur
l'histoire c'est important pour
embrasser et mais l'époque d'aujourd'hui
et quand on dit tous on parle aussi de
la jeunesse ils sont très présents sur
ce salon on a carrément un chapiteau une
tente
voilà donc du plus petit âge
c'est-à-dire du coloriage où on peut
commencer à colorier des chevaliers des
princesses égyptienne jusqu'à
effectivement à l'aja l'âge adolescent
il ya pas mal d'animations avec le
mémorial de caen sur le département avec
voilà y'a plein de il se passe plein de
choses des mises en scène des costumes
il ya une centaine de bénévoles qui sont
costumés qui mène de l'ambiance est
d'abord une fête de l'histoire et on
peut aussi repartis avec un livre et ça
dépasse la dédicace on va dire la simple
jeu mais bien les guillemets avec leurs
contacts des auteurs il ya des
animations il ya des échanges et des
débats vous ouvrir une plus large que
ses formes très très dans chaque minute
il se passe quelque chose soit des cafés
l'auteur intimiste vous pouvez dialoguer
poser des questions avec un auteur à
quelques-uns soyez des grands débats
on va recevoir valéry giscard d'estaing
ancien président qui va dialoguer avec
son biographe
voilà qui vient nous dire ce qu'il faut
retenir de ce septennat de 1974 à 1981
voilà il ya des choses très sérieuses et
puis d'autres plus plus amusante et
ludique 1 depuis quelques années un
nouveau support qui fait qui a fait son
entrée qui mais l'histoire en avance et
la plateforme youtube youtube sont
encore présents alors là on
on appuie vraiment sur le buzz
effectivement c'est un vrai phénomène
sur la toile
on a identifié 40 youtuber qui déposent
régulièrement des vidéos d'histoire et
donc on lance le premier prix du
meilleur youtuber de l'année voilà notre
césar molière à nous et donc ça sera le
vendredi soir une grande cérémonie avec
avec ugc et bnp paribas notre partenaire
et donc on va récompenser les cc
meilleur youtuber de l'année et à l'ugc
sierra leone presque nous étant très
proche de saint quentin en yvelines ce
n'est pas les juger activement le cyrano
de versailles il reste d'ailleurs
déplace donc sur le site donc d'histoire
de lire point fr tous vos auditeurs sont
invités peuvent encore s'inscrire en
ligne
alors cette année vous mettez aussi une
personnalité historique en avant
napoléon cette année c'est lui fait
d'ailleurs il est sur la fiche tout de
ce salon qui au lieu de d'être sur son
cheval marengo il est à cheval sur un
sur un livre alors on a détourné le
tableau de david on a un partenariat
avec la fondation napoléon qui va nous
prêter un certain nombre d'objets
personnels des lettres des livres de
l'empereur et donc il ya une exposition
ouverte au grand public pour découvrir
donc
le napoléon homme amoureux de plumes
homme de lettres voilà on sait qu'il a
écrit plus de 40 mille courriers c'était
un épistolaire comment dirais je
au quotidien stakhanoviste et donc voilà
c'est tout ça qui est présenté dans une
petite exposition mais qui va nous
montrer un apollon comme on le connaît
mal beaucoup de rendez-vous qui depuis
plus de dix ans feber presque vingt
mille visiteurs l'an dernier
comment vous l'expliquer cet engouement
autour de l'histoire je ne les explique
pas je n'explique pas on dit souvent que
la france contrairement à d'autres pays
européens peut être comme les anglais à
est un pays car une vraie passion pour
son histoire d'ailleurs dans les débats
politiques dans les élections il ya
toujours ces questions qui reviennent on
aime se chamailler se disputait donc
peut-être peut-être ça peut expliquer
cela
et puis bon le l'édition l'édition
historique se porte plutôt bien il ya un
phénomène je sais pas si c'est un
phénomène de mode voilà après les ailes
et alain decaux il ya eu un passage à
vide et puis aujourd'hui on parlait d'
de lorànt deutsch ou de deux passeurs
stéphane behr voyez il ya des gens qui
transmettre cette passion et qui rendent
la plus accessible plus populaires
absolument et donc nous on est là pour
accompagner ce mouvement
merci vous aviez un malin le temps on
nous presse on veut alors le salon
histoire de lille c'est samedi 24
novembre et dimanche 25 novembre la
soirée des youtuber c'est le 23 novembre
et tout le programme est disposée est
disponible sur le site qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran l'histoire était aussi à
l'honneur ce week-end à 50 ans divine et
particulièrement la grande guerre on
vient d'en parler en ces temps de
commémoration les archives
départementales des yvelines organisée
une journée autour de 14 18 avec des
animations et des remises de prix
regardé plusieurs années de travail
collaboratif mais aussi plusieurs années
d'émotion
c'est une sorte de clap de fin avec la
fin du centenaire de la grande guerre
les archives départementales ans
célébrés nouvelle fois l'histoire à
travers leurs projets collaboratifs
débuter en 2013
une édition qui clôt un peu ce cycle de
commémoration une édition dont la
programmation a été menée conjointement
avec l'ensemble des bénévoles une
édition que l'on voulait avant tout
festive et qui soit
une sorte d'hommage aux contributeurs
notamment au travers de cette exposition
photos de portraits
ils sont très actifs dans l'ensemble des
projets que l'on mène et sans eux on
pourrait pas arriver à ces résultats les
bénévoles et le public ont voyagé
jusqu'en 1914 en se glissant dans la
peau de poilus du recrutement à l'envoi
de courriers sur le front il y avait une
grosse responsabilité parce que ces
cartes représenter afin de cette
correspondance représente évidemment
beaucoup et puis il fallait aussi bien
entendu dans l'autre sens que les laits
la correspondance écrite par les
familles puissent parvenir
jusqu'aux premières vit une journée
aussi marquée par des remises de prix
les passionnés pouvait partir en équipe
à la recherche de gueule d'ange dans un
serious game
il ya lui huit étapes pour pouvoir
trouver finalement qui est gueule d'ange
on est à la recherche d'un personnage
qui a fait des croquis et donc on essaie
de retrouver le nom de ce gorge
je suis une adepte des archives
départementales dont déjà moi je légers
connaît déjà depuis très longtemps donc
c'était une évidence de fer en fait ce
jeu depuis 2013 plus de 7000 personnes
ont été touchées par l'ensemble des
projets menés par les archives
départementales
une voix légèrement cassée envoûtante
des titres tout droit venu des années 20
sarah lenka manie le jazz avec
gourmandise la jeune artiste française
était sur la scène du théâtre simone
signoret de conflans sainte honorine le
14 novembre dernier
elle participait pour la première fois
au festival blues sur seine retour sur
ce concert
comme j'aime
sarah lenka vous emmène en voyage celui
des chanteuses jazz des années 20 30 le
jazz la jeune artiste le découvre à
londres géré par edge et ou du jazz et
du coup c'est j'ai voulu mélanger
voilà ces deux mondes en fait faire une
passerelle on va dire je suis pas une
fan inconditionnelle
a la base je viens pas du tout blessé
parce que j'écoute est naturellement sur
le jazz pendant des heures mais déjà un
j'ai appris à l'entendre j'ai appris à
l'apprécier comprendre ces subtilités et
puis on va dire que j'ai un jazz qu'elle
tint de folk blues désigné meilleur
artiste vocale féminine par la sacem en
2007 sarah lane qu'un sort un troisième
album en 2016
un hommage à b6 méfie
à
[Musique]
mais si smith elle elle m'a parlé par
son franc parler déjà elle avait une
manière de raconter sa vie et de chanter
ces histoires on s'était pas le bo qui
prime est en fait c'était vraiment voilà
quel que soit le sentiment qu'elle
rejoint quelque chose de beau garçon
quelqu'un de moche je le disais comme
c'était il n'y a pas de filtre et
c'était très triste et très vrai et moi
j'adorais ça c'est aussi une femme une
des premières femmes qui a ouvert le
chemin parce que c'était la première
femme chanteuse noire car là aussi cas
et je pense à important c'est qu'on sert
dégage tantôt de l'humour tantôt de la
puissance avec son timbre éraillé sarr
haleine quatre ans mais son envie de
partager
et vous en vous
[Musique]
du jazz il en sera aussi question à
coignières les amis de l'orgue de la
ville propose chaque année des concerts
autour d'un instrument l'orgue c'est le
trio adrian clark qui est à l'honneur ce
week-end on écoute un extrait il mattino
[Musique]
mais ce cas
vim
et c'est une saison un peu particulière
pour l'association de coignières elle
fête ses 20 ans écoutez son président il
était l'invité de grégory canal et en
octobre dernier
cela représente beaucoup de travail
une centaine de concerts par dont une
centaine de concerts une recherche
d'intervenants d' des programmes
intéressants un peu éclectique et un
public qui nous suit maintenant de façon
très assidu depuis une bonne dizaine
d'années depuis dix ans l'encyclopédie
de la parole collecte toutes sortes
d'enregistrements les classes et créer
et l'une de ses créations bla bla bla se
joue sur la scène nationale de saint
quentin ont nivelé emmanuel lafont vous
êtes la metteuse en scène de bla bla bla
mon jour bonjour c'est une oeuvre qui se
met à hauteur d'enfant oui c'est une
oeuvre qu'on a pensé pour tout le monde
à vrai dire à partir de 7 ans on sait
pourquoi ce genre en la première année
puis maintenant se dit à partir de 7 ans
et pourquoi le choix de sept ans alors
parce que c'est un âge où on est encore
on va dire très ouvert à nous on a
encore plein de plein de lectures des
degrés ni des degrés différents de
d'interprétation va dire de créer 0° un
degré 2
et puis ça correspond à peu près au
moment où on arrive au cp c'est à dire
qu'on sait lire et écrire
et puis on n'a qu'une culture qui s'est
un petit peu diversifiée alors ce sont
des sons des bruits mais quoi si vous
deviez décrire quelques sons qui ont été
choisis pour pour l'oeuvre
ce sont des sons et des bruits que fait
la parole parce que quand on parle et
ben ça fait du son ça fait du bruit
ça dit quelque chose on m'a toujours un
message à transmettre comme on parle
mais ça fait du bruit
et donc ce qu'on entend ce qui se donne
à voir dans le spectacle bla bla bla
c'est des choses qu'on entend tous les
jours qu'on entend quand on a sept ans
quand on a 12 ans quand on a 18 ans 28
ans 58 ans soixante dix huit ans des
choses que tout le monde entend toute la
journée
il ya des choses spécifiques aussi que
n'entendent que les enfants qui vont à
l'école par exemple mais non souvient on
est tous allés à l'école donc c est vous
avez sont peut-être de cour de récré de
oui voilà de démission destinée à des
enfants mais aussi de choses qui se
passent à l'école ou de la maîtresse qui
fait l'appel par exemple d'un animateur
qui va s'adresser aux enfants pendant le
monde la cantine des choses comme ça et
pourquoi avoir choisi alors de mettre en
scène ses sont là qui quel était le défi
peut-être c'était de faire revivre des
souvenirs aux parents de s'intégrer aux
enfants dans leur monde de tous les
jours bah c'est à dire que ça fait
quelques temps qu'on fait des spectacles
au sein d'encyclopédie de la parole pour
adultes et on s'est rendu compte que
c'était une matière qui touchait
tellement de gens c'est des spectacles
qui peuvent paraître un petit peu
incongru parce que il s'annonce pas
comme des spectacles avec une histoire
narrative
c'est des spectacles sont fait de
montages qui sont faits à partir de deux
documents sonores dont qui viennent de
la réalité d'un côté documentaire à la
chose mais il se trouve que on à tourner
ses spectacles dont plein d'endroits
différents en france et aussi à
l'étranger parce qu'il ya pas mal de
langues étrangères dans le spectacle et
on se dit mais c'est tellement ça marche
tellement bien c'est tellement
accessible à tout le monde
il faudrait qu'on puisse toucher un
public encore plus large et s'adressait
aussi aux enfants qui en plus ont un
rapport à la langue extrêmement ludique
extrêmement large extrêmement riche
je propose qu'on regarde un extrait on
continue d'en parler et bienvenue dans
l'émission grandir
aujourd'hui on va voir comment réagit
pour ce faire produit par son temps pelé
de l'autorité et des claquettes baignade
est surveillée aux objets personnels
alors d'iverson mais en personne une
personne sur scène armelle douce et oui
c'est le choix en effet pour faire
entendre la diversité extrême de la
parole humaine le choix est le procédé
selon lequel toutes ces paroles va
traverser une seule personne armelle
doulcet le choix des rebelles doucet
c'est parce que c'est une
c'est une extraordinaire artiste qui est
musicienne et danseuses et qui est qu'il
a fait la comédienne et c'est un vrai
caméléon sur scène elle est l'interprète
tout oui comme n'importe qui peut le
faire enfin il se trouve qu'avec elle on
en a fait un spectacle
en fait tout le monde fait ça on s'amuse
tout le temps faire ça on s'amuse tout
le temps à imiter sa mère au téléphone
sa concierge qu'on entend tous les
matins à la même heure ou alors la voie
par exemple des transports des
transports en commun qu'on a toujours
certains prennent l'italien comme ça
hichem délai voyez quand il faut qu'on
fasse attention à la marche pour
descendre là donc qu'elle fait ça comme
elle le peut il se trouve que bon là on
en a fait un art quand on en a fait un
spectacle
elle a une oreille très musique la pièce
se nourrit au fur et à mesure des
rencontres avec le public où s'est
établie elle ne bouge plus la pièce fx
elle établit elle ne bouge plus sauf que
là j'ai une petite propositions de
coupes prochainement puisque le
spectacle qu'il a sa propre vie il a sa
propre évolution à force de jouer mais
non dans la partition et fx c'est un
moyen aussi peut-être de faire
comprendre aux parents l'importance de
certains mots de se dire on a dit ça
notre enfant c'est ce que s'est pas
adapté ou pas du tout vous nourrissez de
ce qui sort de la bouche des enfants ou
dans leur univers ah non non non non non
c'est pas seulement ce qui sort de la
bouche des enfants parce que les enfants
s'entendent par les eux mêmes leurs
copains mais entend des adultes tout le
temps donc se mettre à hauteur d'enfant
c'est en fait se mettre à écouter le
monde tel qu on le fait des roses
devenir nous-mêmes d enfance et les
adultes non non non non non c'est chacun
sa place
on entend tous tous en partage tous
cette écoute on a tous été en cm1 cm2
sauf qu'on ne l'est plus peut-être que
le cwa lc2 ne ressemble le plus fin le
vocabulaire les registres de langage ont
sans doute évolué par rapport au moment
où on était à l'école mais il y avait
quand même différent registre de langage
est l'occasion je pense que l'occasion
c'est de pouvoir en parler c'est que les
parents et les enfants en sortant du
spectacle pendant le spectacle peuvent
réagir à leur manière à ce qu'ils voient
ce qu'ils entendent et à l'issue du
spectacle peuvent en parler peut vendre
blagues et peuvent se souvenir de ce
qu'ils ont vu ou ne pas se souvenir
chacun chacun à sa manière mais c'est
une expérience vraiment qui est qui est
partagé par les petits et les grands qui
s'est voulue
merci emmanuel lafont de cette
expérience elle est à vivre au théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines c'est du 21
au 24 novembre
on passe maintenant à notre page agenda
des récits mythiques photographier
l'artiste mythe à vostok s'intéresse au
destin de femme à l'âme féminine des
clichés à découvrir jusqu'au 24 novembre
à la galerie jamot à versailles de
l'humour noir des histoires écrites de
manière monstrueuse c'est l'univers de
tim burton qui inspire et emilio
calcagno le chorégraphe crée avec trois
autres artistes les petites histoires
2,4 oeuvre pour dépendre le monde de
l'enfance ses premiers émois ses
cruautés le prisme d'elancourt les
accueille le mardi 27 novembre de la
danse aussi à la ferme de bel ébat de
guyancourt mirage vous entraîne dans une
traversée onirique à des contrées
arctique
christian et françois ben aïm donne vie
à l'invisible au glaz qui fondent
regardez cet extrait
[Musique]
[Rires]
messaoud à zéro raconte notre
emprisonnement liés aux écrans le floch
le flot continu de mots et de sons avec
102 savoir le chorégraphe nous donne des
pistes aussi pour brisé nos chaînes
à découvrir au théâtre espace que je de
plaisir regardez
[Musique]
du rock à la merise trust fête ses 40
ans sur scène et fait escale à trappes
toujours aussi rebelle est remonté vers
les bons voisins et norbert à nono krief
joue le samedi 24 novembre
[Musique]
je
m
un dernier rendez vous aux
clayes-sous-bois avec la hausse et du
hip hop médias raconte la métamorphose
celle de ses danseurs une première
création du chorégraphe met 10 du riz
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
c'est la fin de cette culture merci de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]